today's classic interview is with Todd
Wolfson and it's stunning how in
retrospect it was so prescient at the
time
the interview was in January of 2015 and
the topic was whether there is a cyber
right and this now relates in 2018 to
Russian hacking it relates to memo gate
as we spoke about earlier in the week
with Molly McHugh it relates to the alt
rights use of the Internet it relates to
fake news at the time when we spoke to
Todd Wolfson a lot of those developments
hadn't yet taken place so let's get to
this week's classic interview with Todd
Wolf's wolfson about the potential of a
cyber right from a few years ago I'm
joined today by Todd Wolfson who's an
assistant professor at Rutgers
University co-founder of the media
mobilizing project and also author of
the book digital rebellion the birth of
the cyber left this is a really
interesting topic Todd and I'm curious
to start with do you think that there is
a sort of cyber right or is there
something about the internet that is
inherently conducive to being used for
more progressive causes that's a
fantastic question and it's really great
to have a chance to talk to you David I
do think there's something conducive to
a progressive movement and the internet
at least I mean with with some with a
lot of caveats but but the the
conduciveness is that the Internet as it
was developed has and as many people
mark has a democratic participatory
nature which plays very well to both
traditional progressive positions and
certainly as we see with things like
General Assemblies in the Occupy
movement very much show of parallelism
to the contemporary left or what I'm
calling a cyber left so there is a cyber
right I don't think it is developed and
I think this emerges out of a particular
logic which is much more conducive to a
certain form of life based organizing
and sometimes we see that come through
in particular campaigns I mean I
remember during the 2008 presidential
campaign John McCain's campaigns use of
the internet was just a disaster and as
someone who was kind of engaged with
both campaigns as a journalist to see
how they each used the the tools the
internet provided there was just no
comparison at all to the way that that
President Obama was using it what's your
thought though about the the kind of
anti net neutrality movement because
when we step back the Internet to me
seems inherently kind of like as you
said a democratic and even sort of
libertarian space so to speak and the
anti net neutrality movement seems to me
like it would it would fundamentally
change what the internet is obviously
new trial is is a critical policy battle
that we have in front of us it looks
things are looking better today than
they did it maybe six months ago with
the president being a strong proponent
and hopefully that impacting how the FCC
chair and the FCC itself acts on this so
I don't know well what what's gonna
happen obviously none of us do but I do
think that that having strong net
neutrality rules is critical to the sort
of left progressive movement that we've
seen emerge and and so hopefully it will
continue to and and I think you saw you
know in response to SOPA and PIPA you
know in response to certain sorts of
moves on the around technology policy
that you've seen a certain sort of
progressive movement respond to it in a
very powerful way so I think I think
what we've seen as I left a certain sort
of progressive movement develop around
that neutrality but a much broader
progressive movement that has a stake in
it you talk in your book about what you
described is getting sort of lost in
cyberspace and this is something that
I've considered a little bit when we
talk about groups like anonymous and
their activism or even a lot of what
goes on under the gamergate hashtag
online which is that sometimes online
activism if it exists only online can
get kind of disconnected from the real
world so to speak and the way in which
people interact
off-line talked about that a little bit
how have you observed that yeah I mean
this comes out of my research on the
indie media movement which you know
developed in the late nineties 99 and
was really strong in the mid 2000s and
and what I saw in that movement was a
desire and I would say this is based on
the class position of those who were
primarily in the lead of indie media at
least in the u.s. is which which I mean
to say they were largely middle-class
white college-educated they had
technological proficiency amongst other
things maybe they had journalistic
backgrounds maybe they had organizing an
activist backgrounds but they tended to
see technology as the solution so
instead of taking technology and
embedding it in local struggles they
really worked hard to create really
important technological tools so the
indie media websites of 1999 through the
early 2000s I would argue preciate your
Facebook prefigure Twitter prefigure the
blogging movement and in fact one of the
programmers that was involved in the new
media was one of the programmers
involved in the early stages of Twitter
so the technology and what they figured
out there is quite impressive but I
would argue it comes at the expense of
being embedded in strong local
communities the best independent media
centers are developed in that movement
were ones that were embedded in the
community and those are few and far
between and I think that's a broader
emergent logic of contemporary activism
it's a problem right
and and so one that we need to struggle
against and one that we need to find
corrective corrective measures for do
you think that there are some venues and
maybe the Internet is one of them that
simply doesn't lend itself as well to
conservative ideology and I'll give you
a couple of examples sure in the midst
of the success of the daily show and I
think maybe it predated The Colbert
Report but but maybe around the same
time Fox News wanted to do a
conservative half-hour satirical news
show and they called it the half hour
news hour and it was a disaster I mean
it was it was just a complete disaster
and that started making people think
maybe
there's something about this type of
satire that just doesn't work with
conservative ideology is internet
activism something that you would
consider similar to that in other words
is there's something about the Internet
and conservative ideology that will not
work together or has the right simply
not figured it out yet I would say that
there I would say there's no absolutes
here there are yeah I think that the
Internet is more conducive to a to a
broadly understood progressive politic
but I do think that the right as the
internet changes as it becomes more
corporatized as the spaces become as we
go back to the net neutrality ruling as
these space has become more dominated by
certain interests I do think you're
gonna see development of very strong
right trajectory based movements through
the internet and but I think what you're
arguing is very very interesting yes it
you know something like The Daily Show
is something that plays very well to
progressive politic and then on the
Congress something like am talk radio
tends to play more strongly to a
conservative politic and and I think
that there's a logic and set of
practices problems and and communities
of interest that these movements or
these programs speak to that make them
more conducive to a certain political
vision I'll remind the audience the book
is digital rebellion the birth of the
cyber left we're speaking with the
author Todd Wolfson one of the last
things I want to talk about with you
Todd and this is kind of a big thing is
you talk in the book about horizontal
ISM and this idea that often these
progressive online movements and
sometimes you know even occupy which was
not an online movement have a lack of a
specific leader now some tout that lack
of a specific leader as a good thing
it's democratic it doesn't allow
individuals to to kind of sabotage or or
hold hostage the mission for their own
personal gain
but at the same time it has led to some
problems as well where anybody can sort
of wrap themselves with the hashtag or
the name of the movement and distract or
distort what the message is and it can
it can often lead to lack of clear
how can we suss out whether the the fact
that the Internet provides a platform
for leaderless movements is that a
positive or negative thing net yeah I
would say it tracks these days a little
bit negative
I think obviously this is something to
be held in balance when we look at
Occupy or in the media to very
horizontal formations what we see that's
so important about what they do is that
the horizontal ISM the self-organizing
aspect the lack of a centralized
structure allows for great growth both
in the media and occupy grew and
developed very quickly and powerfully
what they a couple things that they
don't do one they don't they tend to
again favor the leadership of people
with the most social and cultural
capital so when you think about indie
media or even occupy what you don't see
is people who have the who are the most
oppressed people of color poor people
immigrants it's very difficult for them
to take the same sort of leadership that
white college-educated males generally
tend to be able to take because the the
invisible structures of power that
exists in these sorts of formations tend
to dominate in those favored people who
have more social and cultural capital so
an imbalance I think that's a problem so
I think there are good things about it
it lets us build a sense of identity
with the movement when when it's deeply
democratic but we have to think about
building leaders actually I would argue
in these women so we may say we want to
build a thousand leaders but leader
listen intense to me what makes sense is
working with communities that are
oppressed and creating political
education programs so that we build a
clarity connectedness competency and
vision of the kind of world we want to
create and horizontality doesn't lend
itself to those sorts of politics
generally we've been speaking with
professor Todd Wolfson the book is
digital rebellion the birth of the cyber
left very interesting and timely topic
Todd thank you so much for being with us
thanks for having me David I really
appreciate it